- I also noticed though
you were really motivated
to get fit this year.
I wish that'd happened to me,
but can we see the photos
to represent what I'm talking about?
What the hell?
(Busta Rhymes laughs)
What are you doing?
Asking for a friend.
- I think the beautiful thing in life
is the hill and the gully ride, you know?
- Yeah.
- And I was really going through
probably one of my most
challenging times in my life.
I've had some lows like we all go in,
none of us exempt from
actually going through
some sort of hardship,
but I lost my dad in, I believe, 2014,
and I didn't deal with it
in like a real mourning way.
I kind of just drowned myself in work.
- Yeah.
- And I kinda really
neglected to take care of me.
I was at about 340 pounds.
I was having issues with my health,
and wasn't telling anybody.
I had blood, I was on
blood pressure medicine.
I was on two blood pressure
medicines, by the way.
I was on a acid reflux medicine,
and I also had a horrible sleep apnea,
and I was also growing
polyps on my throat.
And it just reached an apex,
and it got to a point where,
you know, my son, my oldest son,
who I had working as my
role manager at the time,
was so disappointed at what he saw in me.
And I never heard that from my son before.
So it was a crossroads,
and I wasn't happy with
the way I was feeling
and the way I was looking at myself.
And I knew in order to put this music out,
I needed to not just sound incredible,
but I needed to feel incredible,
and I needed to look incredible,
and I wanted to make sure
that I had successfully
executed doing everything
that I was able to do within my means
and within my control
and within my ability
to not leave a stone unturned
when it came to securing this win,
which is probably one of
my greatest wins ever.
- Aw, that feels...
That's gotta feel great, man.
Like, I do know that feeling
when you work on something,
you're like, man,
I don't even care how
it works out out there.
It got out of me, I'm so
proud of it, I did it.
That's gotta feel amazing, and.